is at least partially underwater. And so I'm biking, and at one point I realized that my pedals are like underwater. I haven't seen my friends in basically all year. What are you talking about? You're seeing one of your friends right now. What am I, chopped liver? I don't see any of my friends in person. Proctor's like, hmm, should I really let this kid who's completely soaked into a room full of computers?
至少有一部分泡在水里。所以我在骑车，骑着骑着突然发现我的脚踏板都浸在水里了。我基本上整整一年都没见我的朋友们了。你在说什么呢？你现在不就正在和一个朋友说话吗？难道我是个透明人吗？我都不能亲自见见我的朋友们。普罗克特心想，嗯，我真的应该让这个浑身湿透的小孩进一间摆满电脑的屋子吗？
Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode four, recorded on December 13th, 2020. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we're going to be talking about how many programming languages you should learn, why APL and Haskell are worth learning and how to get your scan eyes. We have to read. We don't have to, but I would like to read some feedback. So I sent you a DM saying – you sent me a DM saying we've got to read user feedback. And I sent a DM saying is it good feedback or bad feedback? And I almost like – I almost hope it's bad feedback because I think that's going to be a lot more funny. But, yeah, let's read the user feedback.
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第四期，录制于 2020 年 12 月 13 日。我是康纳。今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯将讨论你应该学习多少门编程语言，为什么 APL 和 Haskell 值得学习，以及如何获得你的“扫描之眼”。我们需要阅读。我们不是非读不可，但我很想读一些反馈。所以我发私信给你说——你发私信给我说我们得读用户的反馈。然后我发私信说这是好反馈还是坏反馈？我甚至几乎——我几乎希望那是坏反馈，因为我觉得那会更有趣。不过，好吧，我们来读读用户的反馈吧。
I'm not sure if i've read all of the feedback uh that we've received i think i have but i haven't come across any that's that's uh negative um but sure we'll highlight well i'm not come on internet up your game we're not asking for negative i'm not personally asking for negative feedback but bryce uh bryce would would appreciate some but anyways uh pablo from linkedin messaged us saying started listening to your podcast and i thoroughly enjoy it listening to you and bryce talk so passionately revitalize my tough love for algorithms with a smiley face emoji can't wait for more episodes so i'm not sure what tough love means, but we appreciate the feedback. Not sure if you have any thoughts on that that you'd like to share, Bryce. Tough love. Well, I think
我不确定我是否读完了我们收到的所有反馈，我想我已经读过了，但我还没遇到任何负面的反馈，不过当然，我们会重点介绍……好吧，我没有，拜托，互联网，拿出点精神来，我们不是在索求负面反馈，我个人并不是在索求负面反馈，但是布莱斯——布莱斯会很感激有一些的。无论如何，来自领英的巴勃罗给我们发消息说：开始听你们的播客，我非常喜欢。听你和布莱斯充满激情地交谈，重新燃起了我对算法的严厉之爱（带着一个笑脸表情符号），等不及听更多期了。所以我不太清楚“严厉之爱”是什么意思，但我们很感谢这个反馈。布莱斯，如果你有什么想法想分享的话，不确定你有没有。严厉之爱。嗯，我想
he may have been referring to the fact that, you know, we're very passionate about algorithms, but we also, you know, pointed out some of the holes and problems with some of the, you know, names and designs of some of the algorithms in C++. So maybe he's sharing the same appreciation for the problems. And we've got two more pieces. We'll limit ourselves to one piece per episode, but we're at episode number four here, so we're catching up. Ahmad, and I apologize if I mispronounce any of these names Ahmad said can't wait for episode 3
他可能指的是这样一个事实，你知道，我们对算法非常充满激情，但同时我们也，你知道，指出了 C++ 中某些算法的一些名称和设计上的漏洞和问题。所以也许他有着同样的对这些问题的欣赏。我们还有两条。每期我们限制自己读一条，但我们现在是第四期了，所以我们在补进度。艾哈迈德，如果有任何名字我发音不准的话我先道个歉，艾哈迈德说等不及要听第三期了
episode 2 was quite interesting first time I heard about the unique pointer array specialization pretty cool amazing podcast so kudos to you for pointing that out educating the masses and then the last one that I was going to read which clearly
第二期非常有趣，我第一次听到关于唯一指针数组特化的消息，非常酷，很棒的播客，所以向你指出这一点、教育大众致以敬意，然后我要读的最后一条，显然
I have moved away from. Awkward pause. I had it all lined up and now it's gone. So I'll find it next time but maybe I'll cut this part out too anyways when we started this podcast Connor was like we're not going to do any editing
我已经把它划过去了。尴尬的停顿。我都准备好了，现在它不见了。所以我下次再找它，不过也许我也把这部分剪掉吧。不管怎样，当我们开始这个播客时，康纳就像是，我们不打算做任何剪辑
it'll be nice and lightweight and every episode except for episode one we've been like oh we're going to have to make all these edits although I think only episode what was last week, three? Only episode three actually required some edits because of our... There's been pretty lightweight. The last episode was quite heavy, but they've been pretty lightweight.
它会很轻松简便，除了第一期之外的每一期，我们都觉得，哦，我们得做所有这些剪辑。虽然我认为实际上只有上周的那期——第三期？只有第三期因为我们的……实际上需要进行一些剪辑。一直以来都挺轻松的。上一期内容相当多，但它们一直都挺轻量级的。
It's mostly the first section that needs to be edited. Anyways, today we're debating. Let me adjust my chair. Get in debate mode. Lock the back so that I'm not slouching. What are we debating? We are debating how many programming languages should you learn. How many? Or whether you should learn more than one. Right. I think it was that. Yes. Whether you should learn more than one programming language. And
基本上只有第一部分需要剪辑。不管怎样，今天我们在辩论。让我调整一下椅子。进入辩论模式。把靠背锁定，这样我就不会驼背了。我们在辩论什么？我们在辩论你应该学习多少门编程语言。多少门？还是说你应该学习不止一门。对。我想是这个。是的。你是否应该学习不止一门编程语言。并且
I will be taking the position of that you should learn more than one. At least a little bit. Well, I think it's really what the debate is. Should you learn a lot of programming languages or should you just focus on a couple of programming languages? And I think I'm going to be team fewer programming languages and you're going to be team more programming languages.
我将持有的立场是，你应该学习不止一门。至少了解一点点。嗯，我认为这才是真正的辩论所在。你应该学习很多编程语言，还是应该只专注于少数几门编程语言？我想我会加入“更少编程语言”战队，而你将加入“更多编程语言”战队。
Yes. I will be arguing one of my favorite tweets of all time from ben dean where he tweeted it'll be in the it'll be in the show notes but he says learn computational paradigms and then lists off c++ lisp haskell small talk prologue fourth apl and it's this is actually from a blog post that he wrote, and later in the blog post, he also mentions Erlang. But I think those eight, feel free to leave comments on either the Reddit where we post this or on Twitter or somewhere or LinkedIn if you think that there's another language that represents a paradigm outside of those eight. But I completely agree. He ends his tweet saying, if you know these, just about everything else is variations. And I completely agree that learning one language from each of those paradigms is a paradigm shift.
是的。我将辩论本·迪恩（Ben Dean）我最喜欢的推文之一，它会被放在节目笔记里，但他说：学习计算范式，然后列出了 C++、Lisp、Haskell、Smalltalk、Prolog、Forth、APL，这实际上来自他写的一篇博客文章，在这篇博客文章的后面，他也提到了 Erlang。但我认为那八个，如果你认为还有另一种语言能够代表这八个之外的范式，请随时在我们发布这个内容的 Reddit 上、或者在 Twitter 上、或者在某处、或者在领英上留言。但我完全同意。他在推特结尾时说，如果你了解这些，几乎其他一切都只是变体。我完全同意，从这些范式中每种学习一门语言就是一次范式的转变。
It's going to completely change the way that you think about problems and that you solve problems. So what do you say to that, Bryce? Nothing. Well, I mean, I should say I don't necessarily, like, as... I've already won. He agrees. As a programming language designer, it would be... It would kind of be hard for me to say
它将彻底改变你的思考方式以及你解决问题的方式。对此你有什么要说的吗，布莱斯？没有。好吧，我的意思是，我应该说我并不一定，比如作为……我已经赢了。他同意了。作为一名编程语言设计者，这会……我要说
that you should only ever look at, you know, a small number of languages. Because when you're designing a programming language, of course, you want to look at other programming languages to draw inspiration. You want to look at what, you know, what's the existing best practice? What's the prior art? But that's sort of with my hat on is somebody that's involved in programming language evolution. As somebody that's, you know, just working on building, you know, software libraries or software frameworks, in that role, I'm not, I don't feel very motivated to go and learn a whole bunch of other languages,
你应该只看少数几种语言，这对我来说有点难。因为当你设计一门编程语言时，当然，你会希望参考其他编程语言来获取灵感。你会希望看看，你知道，现有的最佳实践是什么？以前的做法是什么？但这是我作为一个参与编程语言演进的人所戴的帽子。作为一个仅仅致力于构建软件库或软件框架的人，在那个角色中，我并不感到有很强的动力去学习一大堆其他语言，
except when I really need to. Like the languages that I work in right now are the, we talked about in a past episode how my mentor thought there were three acceptable programming languages, C++, JavaScript, and Python. So I kind of know all those languages. I like to joke I write really bad Python. I also read a lot of Bash. Bash is actually a language that I kind of love. And I'm sure we'll talk about that at length at some point. And then more recently, I've been spending a lot more time with Fortran because Fortran's a very important language to HPC and I work on an HPC compiler
除非我真的需要。比如我现在工作的语言是，我们在过去的一期中讨论过，我的导师认为有三种可以接受的编程语言：C++、JavaScript 和 Python。所以我基本上懂所有这些语言。我喜欢开玩笑说我写非常糟糕的Python。我还读很多 Bash。Bash 实际上是我挺喜欢的一种语言。我确信我们在某个时候会详细讨论它。然后最近，我花在 Fortran 上的时间多得多，因为 Fortran 对 HPC（高性能计算）来说是一门非常重要的语言，我在 NVIDIA 这里从事 HPC 编译器的工作
here at NVIDIA. But I've just never felt the motivation to go and learn every, you know, cool new language or, you know, languages that I'm not going to be using in my day-to-day work. And I just, part of it's just a matter of time management. You know, I've got so much stuff I want to do and I don't necessarily have the spare time to go and learn a language that I'm not, like, that I don't actively have a reason to use. Like, I've recently been going and relearning Fortran, not because I'm particularly excited about, like, not because I personally have a need to learn Fortran, but because I need to use it in my work. And, like, I think Fortran is actually a pretty cool and exciting language. And modern Fortran, in particular, if you look at modern Fortran versus like older Fortran, like it's a whole different language.
但我从来没有感到有动力去学习每一个很酷的新语言，或者那些我不会在日常工作中使用的语言。这其中一部分只是时间管理的问题。你知道，我有太多想做的事情，我未必有空余时间去学习一门我没有积极理由去使用的语言。比如，我最近一直在重新学习 Fortran，不是因为我对它特别兴奋，不是因为我个人有学习 Fortran 的需求，而是因为我需要在工作中使用它。而且，我觉得 Fortran 实际上是一门相当酷且令人兴奋的语言。特别是现代 Fortran，如果你把现代 Fortran 和旧版本的 Fortran 相比，它完全是另一门语言。
But it's just like I learned it because I needed to use it for my job, not because I had some desire to explore it. And I feel like there's so many things to learn within, you know, each different language. I'd rather specialize in a few languages, you know? Like, there's so much to learn in C++. I'd rather focus my efforts on really mastering C++ instead of going off and learning, you know, Go or Ling, APL, etc. So I think part of part of it is just like how do you find the time um yeah yeah i mean i feel like honestly this is a bad debate because like we very quickly have taken our extreme positions and like centered on something like we agree on uh so i'm sure
但我学它只是因为工作需要使用它，而不是因为我有什么探索它的欲望。我觉得在每一种不同的语言中都有太多东西要学。我宁愿专精于少数几种语言，你知道吗？比如，C++ 中有太多东西要学了。我宁愿把精力集中在真正精通 C++ 上，而不是去学 Go、Erlang、APL 等等。所以我觉得部分原因只是在于你怎么挤出时间。是的，是的，我的意思是，说实话，我觉得这是一场糟糕的辩论，因为我们很快就采取了极端的立场，然后集中在一个我们意见一致的观点上……所以我确信
people think that i know languages very well but the truth is is like at one point i heard some people referring uh to me at a conference as like oh he's the haskell guy um and i was like what uh because i guess in a couple of my talks i had just i brought up haskell quite a bit but like i i am not a haskell expert by any means. In fact, like I got six chapters into real world Haskell and then got distracted. And like, that's the extent of my Haskell knowledge. And I've spent a lot of time like studying the prelude and like all the different algorithms
人们认为我非常懂语言，但事实是，有一次我在一个会议上听到有人提到我，说“哦，他是那个 Haskell 专家”，当时我就想，什么？因为我想在我的几次演讲中，我确实比较多地提到了 Haskell，但绝对谈不上我是 Haskell 专家。事实上，我读了《Real World Haskell》的前六章，然后就分心了。这就是我 Haskell 知识的全部广度。我花了很多时间研究标准前奏（prelude）以及几个最受欢迎的库中的各种算法
in a couple of the most popular libraries. But that does not make someone a Haskell expert. And same thing with basically all the other languages that I learn or that I know, I have some knowledge of, like, I would say I have a very surface level understanding of many of the languages that I can write like a simple solution to some programming problem in. So your comment, you know, mastering one language and just sort of knowing a few that you can like write scripts in is actually probably what I would advocate for. But I would say, you know, follow the advice of the pragmatic programmer, which says, you know, attempt to learn a language every year, every couple of years so that you do get exposed to sort of different paradigms. And I wouldn't say it's definitely not worth it to become like an expert
但这并不意味着一个人就是 Haskell 专家。基本上我学习或了解的所有其他语言也是如此，我有一些了解，可以说我对许多语言只有非常表层的理解，我可以用它们写出解决某些编程问题的简单方案。所以你的评论，你知道，精通一门语言，然后只是稍微了解几门可以用来写脚本的语言，实际上可能就是我所倡导的。但我会说，你知道，遵循《程序员修炼之道》的建议，它说，你知道，尝试每年或每隔几年学习一门语言，这样你确实能接触到不同的范式。而且我不会说，花时间成为所有这些范式中每一种语言的专家绝对不值得
in a language from every single one of those paradigms. It's worth it to become an expert in maybe one or two or three, and then just sort of have like no, have a surface level understanding of like in broad strokes like you know how does this language deal with polymorphism like how does this language what do they do for their type system you know um do they have like a dsl for insert this or insert that um well but so like for i think it also might be that you and I are like slightly different types of programmers. And that might also drive our different levels of interest in other languages. Like you're really very much an algorithms guy. You get very, you're very passionate about going out and solving algorithmic problems.
成为一门、两门或三门语言的专家是值得的，然后只需对比如语言如何处理多态性、语言的类型系统是怎么做的、他们是否有用于插入这个或那个的 DSL（领域特定语言）等有一个广泛的、表层的理解……不过，所以我想这也可能是因为你和我属于稍微不同类型的程序员。这可能也是我们对其他语言兴趣程度不同的原因。比如你非常热衷于算法。你对出去解决算法问题充满了激情。
And like that's something that you can go and do in, you know, whatever language. Like I've noticed you've done some of the Advent of Codes. Okay, you should tell me what Advent of Code is. I've seen that you've done some of them on Twitter and APL. I have no idea what it is. So very quickly, and this is anyone that wants to can hop in and start solving them. I was talking to Michael Park at the Bay Area C++
这就像是你在任何语言中都能做的事情。就像我注意到你做过一些“代码日历”（Advent of Code）。好吧，你该告诉我什么是“代码日历”。我看到你在 Twitter 和 APL 上做过一些，但我完全不知道那是什么。所以简单来说，任何想参与的人都可以加入并开始解题。我周三在湾区 C++ 虚拟用户组会议上和迈克尔·帕克（Michael Park）聊过，就在上周三，当时我正和他聊天，然后不知怎么就把他拉进了解“代码日历”的行列。我想他的第一个解法是用 awk 写的，我们可能在某个时候应该做一期关于 awk 的节目。但他每天都在换语言。我想他用的最后一个是用 Rust 写的。不管怎样，“代码日历”，它有点像是一个小型的编程问题竞赛。如果你在前 100 名里，它就是一场竞赛。
virtual user group meeting on Wednesday, this past Wednesday, and was chatting with him and then somehow looped him into starting Advent of Code. He did his first solution in awk, I believe, which we should probably do an episode on at some point. But he's been like changing languages every day. I think the last one he did was in Rust. Anyways, Avent of Code, it's a little programming problem contest, sort of. If you're like in the top 100, it's a contest.
如果你不在前 100 名里，那它就只是一件好玩的事，而我并不在前 100 名里。它只是一件好玩的事。从 12 月 1 日到圣诞节，连续 25 天，每天午夜（美国东部标准时间）他们会发布一道题目。题目分为两个部分。我想这个想法是，从第一天到第 25 天，难度会逐渐增加。
If you're not, then it's just something fun to do, which I am not in the top 100. It's just something fun. Where every day for 25 days from December 1st till Christmas, they release a problem at midnight Eastern Standard Time. And the problem comes in two parts. And I think the idea is that progressively it gets harder from day one till day 25. And a lot of people use it as sort of like,
很多人把它当作一种机会，用来变得更熟悉一门语言或者学习一门新语言。所以他们会选择一门他们在日常生活中不怎么用的语言。并不是所有人，比如我知道特里斯坦·布兰德尔（Tristan Brindles）是用 C++ 解题的。我看到巴里·莱夫津（Barry Revzin）一直在用 Rust 解题。我一直在用
they take it as an opportunity to get more familiar or to learn a new language. So they choose a language that they don't program in day to day. Not everyone, like I know Tristan Brindles, he's solving them in C++. Barry Revzin I've seen has been solving them in Rust. I've been solving them in a combination
Smalltalk 和 APL 的组合来解题，这取决于具体是什么问题。关于“代码日历”，我想说的是，我通常走不了太远，因为很多问题在解析输入方面工作量非常巨大，我有一半的时间都懒得去解析输入——问题本身其实相当简单。只是，你必须从字符串中提取一些信息，尤其是像往年那样，
of small talker apl depending on uh what what the problem is and this is the thing i will say about advent of code is that i typically don't get very far because a lot of the problems are super heavy on like parsing the input and i half the time can't be bothered to like just parse input like the problem itself is quite easy. It's just, you have to extract some information from like strings and especially like, you know, years past,
我从来没有用除 C++ 之外的其他语言做过。C++ 众所周知并不是一门适合解析字符串的语言。我注意到很多编程比赛，比如我在各种会议上看到的一些比赛，往往非常偏向字符串处理。而且，我有一个理论，原因在于设计这种自包含的挑战更容易，其中你的输入全部都是字符串。就像可能会有有趣的算法问题，其输入不是字符串，但这需要更多的设置。比如，如果你有更复杂的数据类型等等。而字符串相对容易设置。但是，我同意你的看法，如果问题只是归结为解析某些输入字符串或格式化
I'd never done it in any other language other than C++. C++ is infamously not a good language for like parsing strings. I've noticed a lot of like coding competitions, like some of the ones that I've seen at various conferences tend to be very, like, string-oriented. And, like, I have a theory that the reason for that is that it's easier to engineer sort of self-contained challenges where your inputs are all just strings. Like, there might be interesting algorithmic problems where the inputs aren't strings, but, like, that requires a little bit more setup. Like, if you've got more complex data types, et cetera. Whereas like strings are fairly easy to set up. But like, I agree with you, like if the problem just like boils down to like either parsing some input string or formatting
某些特定方式的输出字符串，那对我就不是特别有吸引力。是的。这就是问题所在，有些题目并不是这样的，前几天有个非常酷的题目，归结起来基本上就是：你有一个数字列表。如果你对它们进行排序，可以保证所有的差值要么是 1，要么是 3。所以计算一下差值为 1 的有多少个，差值为 3 的有多少个，然后把这两个数字相乘。如果你生活在算法的世界里，你可以非常非常优雅地直接调用：排序、管道、相邻差值、管道求频率、管道求值、管道相乘，这就完成了。如果你不生活在算法的世界里，那你就会有一堆 for 循环，代码看起来会非常凌乱。所以像这样的问题，我认为太棒了，
some output string in a certain way, that's just like not super exciting to me. Yeah. And that's the thing is some of them aren't like there was a really cool problem the other day that boiled down to basically like you have a list of numbers. If you sort them, you're guaranteed that all the differences will either be one or three. So like figure out how many differences of one there are, figure out how many differences of three there are, and then multiply those two numbers. And if you live in algorithm land, you can very, very nicely just go sort, pipe, adjacent difference, pipe frequencies, pipe values, pipe multiply, and you're done. And if you don't live in algorithms land, then you're gonna have a bunch of for loops, and it's gonna look super messy. So like problems like that, I think are awesome that like,
而且你所做的基本上只是解析整数。所以这超级棒。但其他的一些题目，它们给你一个用空格和逗号分隔的句子，你需要从三个不同的分区中提取最后两个单词，这就很烦人了。不管怎样，这就是“代码日历”。这个是怎么扯出来的？或者你说你看到我在用 APL。为什么？
and all you're doing is parsing basically integers. So that's super fine. But other ones, they give you a sentence that's space and comma delimited, and you need to pull the last two words in three different partitions, and it's just irritating. Anyway, so Advent of Code. How did this come up? Or you said you saw me in APL. Why?
而且你所做的基本上只是在解析整数。所以这非常棒。但其他的，它们给你一个由空格和逗号分隔的句子，你需要从三个不同的部分中提取最后两个单词，这真的很烦人。不管怎样，关于 Advent of Code。这个是怎么来的？或者你说你在 APL 中看到了我。为什么？
That's the question. Why? Why? Because, yeah, why do I love learning other languages? It starts with Haskell. When I learned Haskell, my mind was blown in that I had been learning the algorithms and seeing a little bit of functional programming and that you can pass, you know, function objects or lambdas to algorithms to customize the behavior. So you can take a simple accumulate and change how it works. And that's very powerful.
这就是问题所在。为什么？为什么？因为，是的，为什么我喜欢学习其他语言？这一切始于Haskell。当我学习Haskell时，我的世界观被颠覆了，因为我一直在学习算法，看到了一点函数式编程，你可以传递，你知道的，函数对象或lambda到算法中来定制行为。所以你可以拿一个简单的累加并改变它的工作方式。这非常强大。
Okay, but you can do that in C++ too. So that's what I'm saying. You can do that in C++, but it's limited to what you're given a set of algorithms in the algorithm and numeric headers. And you can write your lambdas. But you're limited to the extent of how many algorithms you get. You get like whatever, 100 plus or minus.
好吧，但你也可以在C++中做到这一点。这就是我想说的。你可以在C++中做到这一点，但它局限于你在算法和数值头文件中被赋予的一组算法。你可以编写你的lambda。但你的局限在于你能得到多少种算法。你大概有100种左右，上下浮动。
And you can't do anything nice, like really nice. So like if I want to add, if I want to create a unary operator that just adds one to a number, the spelling of that in C++ is bracket, bracket, paren, auto, e, n, paren, brace, return, e, plus one, semicolon, brace, paren, you're done. That hurts my soul a little bit. C++ did an amazing job getting lambdas into C++11, but it hurts my soul a little bit. Then I went to Haskell. First, I learned the lambda syntax, which honestly isn't a lot better, but like the equivalent of that in Haskell
而且你做不出什么真正优雅的东西，比如非常优雅。所以如果我想添加，如果我想创建一个一元运算符，它只是给一个数字加一，在C++中的拼写是方括号，方括号，圆括号，auto，e，n，圆括号，花括号，return，e，加一，分号，花括号，圆括号，这就完成了。这有点让我感到心痛。C++在把lambda引入C++11方面做得非常出色，但这稍微有点让我心痛。然后我去了Haskell。首先，我学习了lambda语法，老实说它并没有好到哪里去，但类似于Haskell中的那种
is paren slash e arrow e plus one n paren. So still not super elegant, but it's a lot shorter. And then I learned about something called sections in Haskell, which are basically terse lambdas. So if you take a binary operator like plus, and you just put parens around it, so three characters, paren, paren plus, and paren, that is a binary operator that adds two things together. If you insert a one on either side of the plus, so if you have paren plus one and paren,
是圆括号斜杠e箭头e加一n圆括号。所以依然不是超级优雅，但它短得多。然后我了解到Haskell中一种叫做片段（sections）的东西，它们基本上是简洁的lambda。因此，如果你采用像加号这样的二元运算符，然后只需在它周围加上圆括号，也就是三个字符，圆括号，圆括号加号，以及圆括号，这就是一个将两个东西相加的二元运算符。如果你在加号的任意一侧插入一个1，也就是说如果你有圆括号加号1和圆括号，
you then change that binary operator that does plus to a unary operation that just adds one. So like in three characters, I defined a binary operation. And in four characters, just by binding a value to either side of the binary operation plus, I've created a unary operation. And, like, that's just syntax. Like, you really haven't learned anything at that point. Yeah, are you, like, being charged by the character or something?
你就可以把那个执行加法的二元运算符变成一个只加1的一元运算。所以，就像用三个字符一样，我定义了一个二元运算。而通过将一个值绑定到二元运算加号的任一侧，我仅用四个字符就创建了一个一元运算。而且，这只是语法。就像，你在那个时候真的什么都没学到。是的，你是在按字符计费还是怎么着？
You know, it makes me a lot happier. So that's the thing. It makes me happy. Like, when I learned about sections, like, I was just like, oh, my God, goodness. Like, this is amazing. But then, like, you start to learn about ways that like you can manipulate these things. So they have like, we technically in Boost HANA have a template metaprogramming function called flip, which they have the equivalent in Haskell.
你知道，这让我快乐得多。就是这样。这让我感到快乐。就像当我了解到片段时，我就觉得，哦，我的天哪。这太棒了。但随后，你开始了解可以操纵这些东西的方法。所以他们有，我们在Boost HANA中技术上有一个名为flip的模板元编程函数，Haskell中也有等价的函数。
So like if you need to flip a binary operation that's like not associative or commutative so that it applies the arguments in the reverse order you can just like compose a function in Haskell called flip with that binary operation and you're done like in C++ unless if you're like doing something in template metaprogramming land and you have access to boost hana there's there's no way to do that like the only way to do that is to wrap your function inside a lambda or there's a couple ways to do it but the simplest way is to wrap your binary function in a lambda and then like reverse the order that you're passing your arguments uh to that function which is irritating um but like in other languages you can just compose
所以如果你需要翻转一个二元运算，它不是结合律或交换律的，这样它会以相反的顺序应用参数，你就可以在Haskell中把一个叫做flip的函数与那个二元运算组合起来，然后就完成了。在C++中，除非你在模板元编程领域做某些事情并且你可以访问boost hana，否则没有办法做到这一点，唯一的办法就是把你的函数包装在一个lambda里面，或者有几种方法可以做到，但最简单的方法是将你的二元函数包装在一个lambda中，然后反转你传递给该函数的参数顺序，这很烦人，但像在其他语言中你只需组合
a a function called flip with your other function and you're done um and like that's just that's just like the tip of the iceberg and so like as i started like going down the haskell path it just it just the way that they um you know the way that they had pattern matching like that was the first time i'd really seen like pattern matching in a language was when i learned haskell like i knew it was coming in c++ and later on i would read, you know, Michael's paper. But like seeing how Haskell dealt with pattern matching and guard statements is just extremely elegant. So it just changed the way that like I saw that problems could be solved. And then I stumbled across APL. And if like, if the difference from C++ to Haskell was an order of magnitude, the difference from C++ to APL
一个叫做flip的函数与你的其他函数，然后就完成了。这只是冰山一角。所以当我开始沿着Haskell的道路前行时，他们的方式，你知道的，他们处理模式匹配的方式——那是我第一次在语言中真正看到模式匹配，当我学习Haskell的时候。我知道它会来到C++中，后来我会读到，你知道的，Michael的论文。但看到Haskell如何处理模式匹配和守卫语句（guard statements）简直极其优雅。所以它改变了我看待问题可以被解决的方式。然后我偶然发现了APL。如果说从C++到Haskell的差异是一个数量级，那么从C++到APL的差异
is like two or three orders of magnitude. Like the solution that I most recently solved for Advent of Code had to do with basically, they say picture a grid that represents an airport waiting area. So there is a sequence of chairs, which are represented by the character L. And then there's everything else in between that's a period.
就像两个或三个数量级。就像我最近为Advent of Code解决的解决方案，基本上是说，想象一个代表机场候机区的网格。所以有一系列椅子，由字符L表示。然后是介于两者之间的所有其他东西，都是句点。
It's just empty space that you can walk around. And it is, honestly, it's a spin on the Conway's Game of Life problem. I won't attempt to explain, or do you want to, well, let's stay on topic. Let's finish the problem, and then you can attempt to explain Conway's Game of Life if you want. I can attempt to explain it? If you want. Other than that, otherwise we'll just link a YouTube video. But anyways, Conway's Game of Life, famous problem.
它只是你可以四处走动的空白空间。而且老实说，它是康威生命游戏（Conway's Game of Life）问题的一个变体。我不会试图解释，或者你想——好吧，我们切入正题吧。让我们完成这个问题，然后如果你愿意，你可以尝试解释康威的生命游戏。我可以尝试解释它吗？如果你想的话。除此之外，否则我们就只放一个YouTube链接。但无论如何，康威的生命游戏，一个著名的问题。
This is sort of a variation of it where it says each iteration of people sitting down, if every adjacent possible seat to them is empty, then that seat becomes taken. And if there are four or more people sitting adjacent to you, then that person gets up and leaves. So those are the rules of like, if you start off completely empty, the second iteration, every seat will be filled. And then the third iteration, any seat that has four or more people sitting next to it will become empty. And then it just sort of repeats. The way that you solve this in APL is like, is mind blowing. Like modern APL actually has something called a stencil operator, which specifically takes like a N by M region of your two dimensional thing.
这有点像是它的一个变体，它说人们坐下的每一次迭代，如果他们身边的每一个相邻可能的座位都是空的，那么那个座位就会被占用。如果有四个人或更多人坐在你旁边，那么那个人就会站起来离开。所以这就是规则，如果你从完全空着开始，第二次迭代时，每个座位都会被填满。然后第三次迭代时，任何旁边坐着四个或更多人的座位都会变空。然后它就会这样重复。你在APL中解决这个问题的方式简直令人震撼。现代APL实际上有一种叫做模板（stencil）操作符的东西，它专门获取你的二维事物的N乘M区域。
It's like a popular trick and like NumPy like libraries. But like the old school way of doing it, it's honestly going to be so hard to explain but it involves a bunch of rotates you know Sean Parent's favorite algorithm for the win where basically you're creating a 3x3 matrix of the original matrix so you have a matrix of matrices
这就像是NumPy等库中的一种流行技巧。但老派的做事方式，老实说太难解释了，它涉及到一堆旋转，你知道的，肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）最喜欢的算法获胜，基本上你是在创建原始矩阵的3x3矩阵，所以你有一个矩阵的矩阵
where each of the 9 matrices that makes up the outer matrix is, has a one rotate applied in every direction to the original matrix. So like the top left has like a one rotate to the left, the top right has like a one rotate to the right, and then you can imagine like rotates in both directions so that, uh, you have the diagonals anyway. So you end up with like eight different, uh,
其中构成外部矩阵的9个矩阵中的每一个，都对原始矩阵在各个方向应用了一次旋转。所以左上角向左旋转了一次，右上角向右旋转了一次，然后你可以想象两个方向的旋转，这样，无论如何你都有了对角线。所以你最终得到了大约八个不同的，
rotated versions of the initial one. And if you just do like a summation across all of those original, uh, or rotated matrices, you end up with like a matrix that represents the number of adjacent, uh, seats that are actively um being sat in and like i would never ever in a million years like think to solve it that way um and
初始版本的旋转版本。如果你对所有这些原始的，或旋转的矩阵进行求和，你最终会得到一个矩阵，它代表了相邻座位的数量，这些座位正在被积极地占用，而我一百万年里也绝对不会想到用这种方法来解决它，并且
unless if i was like learning apl and like learning the apl way to solve things anyways i will end my digression does it but do you do you does that knowledge like you don't you don't write apl code in your day job no um well so i will say uh what the one main thing that was so awesome about that story is when i got the code to work like i i literally like i let out like a yelp of excitement um when i got that code working like it felt it was amazing i i know that uh yelp i've heard that connor yelp before it was like because i honestly i had didn't know how to do conway's game of life and apl and i was working walking through a tutorial and i was like i honestly don't even know i was just typing in like one zero negative one rotate and i'm watching all these numbers pop on my screen. I did not understand it. By the end I did.
除非我正在学习APL并学习用APL的方式来解决问题。无论如何，我要结束我的题外话。但这，你，那种知识会让你——你不会在日常工作中编写APL代码，对吧？不，嗯，好吧，我要说的是，那个故事最棒的主要一件事是，当我让代码运行起来时——我字面意思上地，当代码运行成功时，我发出了兴奋的尖叫——感觉太棒了。我知道那个尖叫，我以前听康纳尖叫过，因为老实说我不知道怎么在APL中做康威生命游戏，我当时正在跟着一个教程学习，然后我想，老实说我甚至不知道，我只是在输入像1、0、负1旋转，然后我看着所有这些数字弹到我的屏幕上。我当时并不理解。到最后我理解了。
But your point is, you know, okay, that's great. You've learned to think differently. Like, but you're not writing an APL day to day. So like, what's the point? The point is that like, it has like, I thought I had good algorithm knowledge when I learned Haskell. Like I, it was pretty good when I was learning C++. Then I went to Haskell and then I had good algorithm knowledge when I learned Haskell. It was pretty good when I was learning C++. Then I went to Haskell, and then I had a bunch of insights. For instance, adjacent difference. It's a terrible name. It encodes the default operation of minus into the name of the algorithm. I had that realization because in Haskell, there's an algorithm called map adjacent. Our map is called transform. So the equivalent sort of translated back to C++ name is transform adjacent. And so then I thought like,
但你的观点是，你知道的，好吧，这很好。你学会了不同的思考方式。但是你并不是每天都在写APL。所以，意义何在？意义在于，它有——我以为我在学习Haskell时有很好的算法知识。当我学习C++时，它相当不错。然后我去了Haskell，接着我在学习Haskell时也有了很好的算法知识。当我学习C++时，它相当不错。然后我去了Haskell，接着我有了很多见解。例如，相邻差（adjacent difference）。这是一个糟糕的名字。它将减法的默认操作编码到了算法的名字中。我有这种领悟是因为在Haskell中，有一个算法叫做map adjacent。我们的map叫做transform。所以翻译回C++的等效名字是transform adjacent。所以我想，
oh yeah, that makes sense. And the Haskell version doesn't come with the default binary operation. You have to specify it. And like when I saw that in Haskell, I realized, yeah, we messed that up in C++. We should have just called our adjacent difference adjacent transform and not encoded a default binary operation because you lose sight of the fact that you can do other things with adjacent difference. One of the things I highlighted in my very first talk is that you can calculate Fibonacci numbers with adjacent difference because it's really adjacent transform. And if you substitute the minus for plus, you have a Fibonacci generator. Based on if you feed the inputs incorrectly. And so like I learned things about C++ from Haskell.
哦，是的，这讲得通。Haskell版本没有附带默认的二元运算。你必须指定它。当我在Haskell中看到这一点时，我意识到，是的，我们在C++中搞砸了。我们本应该把我们的相邻差叫做adjacent transform，而不是编码一个默认的二元运算，因为你会忽略这样一个事实，即你可以用相邻差做其他事情。我在我的第一场演讲中强调的事情之一是，你可以用相邻差计算斐波那契数，因为它实际上是adjacent transform。如果你把减号替换为加号，你就拥有了一个斐波那契生成器。这取决于你是否正确输入了输入。所以我从Haskell中了解到了关于C++的事情。
And the exact same thing happened for APL. Like I've learned a ton about algorithms. Like really, arguably, APL should be I've learned a ton about algorithms, like really, arguably APL should be called the algorithm programming language, not a programming language. But I think that's what it actually stands for is a programming language. Yeah, it stands for a programming language based on a 1962 book that Ken Iverson, the guy that wrote the language wrote, honestly, they didn't know what to call it. It was originally called Iverson notation.
APL也发生了完全相同的事情。我了解了大量关于算法的知识。可以说，APL其实应该被称为算法编程语言，而不是一门编程语言。但我想这确实是它的实际含义，即一门编程语言。是的，它代表一门基于1962年由编写该语言的肯·艾verson（Ken Iverson）所写的一本书的编程语言，老实说，他们当时不知道该叫它什么。它最初被称为艾verson符号（Iverson notation）。
And then he wrote a book about it called A Programming Language. And then in the 60s, IBM was like, hey, we could probably implement this. And then they started implementing it in like 66 and 67. And then at that time, like they didn't have a name for it. And like they were trying to figure out a good name for this language. And then at some point, someone walked in and was just like, about we just call it apl after the book and then everyone sort of shrugged their shoulders and said okay um anyways this is supposed to be a debate now i've just started talking about i'm gonna maybe modify my answer to you should have at least one person on your squad like connor so that you have somebody that has all this knowledge that you can uh
然后他写了一本关于它的书，叫做《A Programming Language》（一门编程语言）。然后在60年代，IBM觉得，嘿，我们大概可以实现这个。然后他们在66年和67年左右开始实现它。当时，他们还没有名字，并且他们在试图为这门语言想一个好名字。然后有一天，有人走进来，说：“不如我们根据这本书叫它APL吧”，然后大家都耸耸肩说“好吧”。无论如何，这本应是一场辩论，现在我一直在谈论，我可能会修改我对你的回答：你的团队里至少应该有一个像康纳这样的人，这样你就能拥有一个拥有所有这些知识的人，你可以
you can extract for your purposes but uh see for me for me it's just like I mean again maybe it's just a difference in like what we do um I don't spend a lot of day-to-day time like writing algorithms anymore or even like writing code I'm doing more like architectural stuff. Um, and so maybe it's just because we're like, we do different things, uh, that it's, uh, it's more valuable for you than for me. Um, yeah, it's just like, I don't know, I don't know where I'd find the time. Um, and, uh, it's certainly, I, I could see it being very interesting and exciting to go and learn a language like APL. I'm just not sure that it would do anything useful for me. Plus, I've already got you who's learned it.
你可以为了解题目的目的而提取这些知识，但是对我和我来说，就像是——再次强调，也许这只是我们所做事情的差异——我不再花很多日常时间写算法，甚至不写代码，我做更多的是架构方面的事情。所以，也许这只是因为我们做的事情不同，这对你来说比对我更有价值。是的，就像是，我不知道，我不知道我在哪里能抽出时间。而且，当然，我能看出学习像APL这样的语言会非常有趣和令人兴奋。我只是不确定它能为我做任何有用的事情。另外，我已经有你了，而你已经学会了。
This is the thing. As I was going to say, you guys can all, or I apologize. I said guys. Everyone can just watch the future talks that I will give that will just be condensations of everything I learned in language X and skip the learning part, although it's probably not the same. But yeah, I mean, definitely it's job dependent. I happen to work on a library that is heavily built on top of algorithms, the thrust algorithms. And a lot of the times it's figuring out how do we implement another algorithm in terms of like the existing algorithms.
这就是重点。正如我正要说的，你们都可以，或者我很抱歉。我说了“你们”。每个人都可以观看我将要进行的未来演讲，那将是我在语言X中学到的一切的浓缩，并跳过学习的部分，尽管可能不一样。但是，是的，当然这取决于工作。我碰巧从事一个严重建立在算法之上的库的工作，也就是thrust算法。很多时候，弄清楚我们如何根据现有算法来实现另一个算法。
So like having a strong knowledge of algorithms is like very important for the work that I do day to day. Like for instance, the other day, I thought this was awesome. A colleague was implementing something called forward fill. So in a data frame, I'll use the pandas and our Python API terminology. So you have a series, which is basically just a column or a vector, if you will. And we have an algorithm called replace nulls. So you can have, it's basically like a vector of optional data.
所以对算法有深入的了解对于我日常的工作非常重要。比如，前几天，我觉得这太棒了。一位同事正在实现一个叫做前向填充（forward fill）的东西。所以在数据框中，我将使用pandas和我们的Python API术语。所以你有一个序列（series），它基本上只是一个列或向量，如果你愿意的话。我们有一个叫做replace nulls的算法。所以你可以拥有，它基本上就像是一个可选数据的向量。
So you can either have, you know, optionals that have the values or ones called replace nulls. So you can have, it's basically like a vector of optional data. So you can either have, you know, optionals that have the values or ones that are null opt. And so there's an algorithm that we have called replace nulls that goes through and you just specify a value and anything that's a null value, they replace with that value. There's a variant of that algorithm called forward fill, which instead of specifying a value, you just take the preceding value, the which instead of specifying a value, you just take
所以你要么拥有带有值的可选对象，要么拥有被称为replace nulls的东西。所以你可以拥有，它基本上就像是一个可选数据的向量。所以你要么拥有带有值的可选对象，要么拥有为null opt的对象。所以我们有一个名为replace nulls的算法，它会遍历并让你指定一个值，任何是null值的东西，它们都会用那个该值替换。该算法有一个变体叫做前向填充，它不是指定一个值，而是获取前一个值，它不是指定一个值，而是获取
the preceding value, the preceding non-null value, and replace that with the null value. So for instance, if you have 1, null, 3, null, 5, a forward fill will replace the first null with the preceding 1 and the second null with the preceding 3. So you end up with 1, three three five so the question is for the listeners and for bryce do you know what algorithm that is not off the top of my head no so we'll give we'll give the listeners uh a couple more seconds well it's it's some sort of a JSON algorithm, obviously. Or I'm guessing it's some sort of a JSON algorithm because you've got to look at the last element.
前一个值，前一个非null值，并将其替换为null值。例如，如果你有1、null、3、null、5，前向填充将用前面的1替换第一个null，用前面的3替换第二个null。所以你最终得到1、3、3、5。所以问题是，对于听众和布莱斯（Bryce），你知道那是什么算法吗？我记不太清了，不知道。所以我们给听众再留几秒钟的时间。好吧，这显然某种JSON算法。或者我猜它是某种JSON算法，因为你必须查看最后一个元素。
So you need some sort of stencil where you're looking at multiple elements at the same time. Unless you've got some sort of stateful thing where you're storing what the last element was. But I don't like such things because they're harder to paralyze uh yeah so if you were guaranteed i think that um you only ever had uh nulls that were you didn't have like a sequence of nulls one one after another, that would definitely work. You could do an adjacent transform, a.k.a. what we call an adjacent difference,
所以你需要某种模板，在其中同时查看多个元素。除非你有某种有状态的东西，存储最后一个元素是什么。但我不喜欢这样的东西，因为它们更难并行化。是的，所以如果你能保证，我认为你永远只有null，你不会有一连串的null一个接一个，那绝对行得通。你可以做一个相邻变换（adjacent transform），也就是我们所说的相邻差（adjacent difference），
and that would work. The problem is what happens if we take our original example and get rid of the middle three and you have one null, null, null, five. If you're doing it sequentially then you're still fine because you you know you you replace the the first null and then it becomes a number and then you by the time you get to the second null you know the thing on its left has been which was a null has been replaced with a with a one already yeah i think actually that would work. Is that defined behavior? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
那就可以了。问题是，如果我们把原来的例子拿掉中间的三个，变成1、null、null、null、5，会发生什么？如果你是按顺序做的，那么你仍然没问题，因为你知道你替换了第一个null，然后它变成了一个数字，当你到达第二个null时，你知道它左边的那个曾经是null的东西已经被1替换了。是的，我认为实际上这会起作用。那是定义的行为吗？是的，是的，是的。
If it's a sequential algorithm, yes. I mean, if we're talking parallel, then things get a little bit more complicated. In some ways, this reminds me of stream compactation, which is an algorithm where you want to go and find like runs of numbers of the same value and compact them to, or you want to go find runs of elements of the same value and compact
如果它是一个顺序算法，是的。我的意思是，如果我们讨论并行，那么事情就会变得稍微复杂一些。在某些方面，这让我想到了流压缩（stream compaction），这是一个算法，你想去寻找相同数值的数字运行并将它们压缩，或者你想去寻找相同数值的元素运行并压缩
them to a single element. Yes, encoding is what that's classically referred to. Sorry to keep everybody hanging, but the answer to the question or problem is to use something that in Thrust is called an inclusive scan.
它们归纳为单一元素。是的，编码就是这个词的经典指代。抱歉让大家久等了，不过这个问题的答案是使用Thrust中被称为包含性扫描（inclusive scan）的技术。
Yeah, that was actually my first intuitive thought was that kind of sounds like a scan. But then my second thought was that might be inefficient because you don't need the sum of everything, right? Well, so that's the thing is classically a scan, the default operation of the scan in C++ is partial sum. So basically a scan is a transform that just carries state with it. And classically in C++, the default operation is std plus, which that means that like at every point in time, the state that you are carrying is the rolling sum of all of the elements that you visited so far. But you don't actually need to carry like state that is the sum of everything. There is something called a scan max um or a scan min which all it does is
是的，其实我最初的直觉想法是，那听起来有点像扫描。但我的第二个想法是，这可能会效率低下，因为你不需要所有东西的总和，对吧？嗯，这就是关键所在，传统意义上扫描的默认操作在C++中就是部分和。所以基本上扫描是一个自带状态的转换。在C++中，默认操作通常是std plus，这意味着在每一个时间点，你携带的状态是你迄今为止访问过的所有元素的滚动总和。但实际上你并不需要携带所有元素之和这样的状态。有一种叫做扫描最大值（scan max）或扫描最小值（scan min）的东西，它的作用只是
carries a single value that represents the minimum of the values you've seen so far and so in this example when you're scanning all you're doing is basically scanning with the previous element um and then you basically have a ternary operator where you check like uh is the current element null uh if it is just use the previous element that is the state that you're carrying return that otherwise just return the current value and the way that that works out is that if you end up with consecutive nulls it will always be returning the last previously non-null value yeah this also kind of reminds me of of group by algorithms.
携带一个代表你迄今为止看到的值的最小值的单一值，所以在这种情况下，当你进行扫描时，你所做的基本上就是用前一个元素进行扫描，然后你基本上有一个三元运算符来检查，比如：当前的元素是空吗？如果是，就直接使用前一个元素，那就是你所携带的状态，返回它；否则就直接返回当前值。这样做的效果是，如果你最终遇到连续的空值，它总是会返回上一个非空值。是的，这也让我想起了分组（group by）算法。
But yes, I'm not surprised to hear you say scan because that was the first thing that jumped out at me. But the thing is, I initially thought scan and then I wasn't certain that it actually worked
不过是的，听到你说是扫描我并不感到惊讶，因为那是第一个让我眼前一亮的东西。但问题是，我最初想到了扫描，然后我并不确定它是否真的起作用
due to the sort of case with the extra nulls and I couldn't see it. But what's beautiful is that I think this is like, I think identifying min scans, max scans, you know, plus scans, those are all pretty easy.
由于带有额外空值的那种情况，我没看出来。但美妙之处在于，我认为这就像——我认为识别最小扫描、最大扫描，你知道的，加法扫描，这些其实都挺简单的。
Like whenever you need to see those, like in my first algorithm intuition talk, when you have to calculate like the mountain range, which is basically identify the maximum and then do a plus scan from both sides. It's pretty easy to see that. But like this is a non-classical scan i would say like in my opinion that is it is definitely a scan um but unless if
就像每当你需要看到这些时，比如在我第一次讲算法直觉时，当你必须计算类似山脉的东西时，这基本上就是识别最大值，然后从两边做加法扫描。这挺容易看出来的。但像这个，我会说是一个非经典的扫描，在我看来，这绝对是一个扫描，但是除非
you like spent if unless if you're mark harris and like you spend your your days thinking about like he he said like once you have your scan eyes this is mark harris uh the pick on my team um he was like once you have your scan eyes, you see it everywhere. And I thought that was like a great quote because I don't spend like a ton of my time thinking about like scans. So I wasn't convinced. But when I presented this in like a lightning talk meeting or more accurately, one of my colleagues, Michael Wang, presented it. And then like a couple people immediately when I was like, what's the algorithm? They were like scan, scan.
如果你像——除非你是马克·哈里斯（Mark Harris），你把时间都花在思考上——他曾经说过，一旦你有了“扫描眼”，这就是马克·哈里斯，我团队里的明星——他说过，一旦你有了“扫描眼”，你到处都能看到它。我觉得这是一句很棒的名言，因为我并没有花大量时间去思考扫描。所以我当时并不确信。但当我在一次闪电演讲会议上提出这个观点时，或者更准确地说，我的同事迈克尔·王（Michael Wang）提出了它，然后有几个人立刻就说——当我问算法是什么时——他们异口同声地说：扫描，扫描。
And because they just they have their scan eyes. If have your scan eyes you see them everywhere um yeah i think this is awesome i'm pretty sure that my adjacent uh transform approach works if you only care about doing this sequentially but if you if you care about doing this in parallel the problem is if you've got like if i've got like one no no five um and let's say that i i divide i divide that four element input sequence into two element chunks each one that's given to a separate thread that second right chunk is going to be null five. And I guess the more nefarious case would be what if you had one – no, no, no. That's the sufficiently nefarious case. In that case, the second thread doesn't know what to do. But I also think – no, I can't really do it with a transformer.
因为他们就是有他们的“扫描眼”。如果你有“扫描眼”，你到处都能看到它们。嗯，我觉得这太棒了。我很确信，如果你只关心串行执行，我那个相邻转换的方法是管用的；但如果你关心的是并行执行，问题就在于，如果你有——比如说我有一个空、空、5，然后假设我把那个四元素的输入序列分成两个元素的块，每个块给一个单独的线程，那第二个右边的块将是“空、5”。我想更恶劣的情况会是，如果你有“1、空、空、空”。那是足够恶劣的情况。那样的话，第二个线程就不知道该做什么了。但我也觉得——不，我真的没法用转换器来做这个。
Yeah, I guess it's got to be a scan if you're doing it in parallel um but if you're doing it in in serial um i think uh just like an adjacent transform would work fine if you just if you know that you're always um marching serially from left to right yeah i i think we're getting close to the end but but I'll link what Bryce just said makes sense to me. But I'm guessing to a lot of the listeners, sort of the parallel versus serial when it comes to like adjacent transform versus scan. There's like a subtle thing that he's relying on. And we can try to explain it in a couple of sentences here. But there's a one of
是的，我想如果你在并行执行的话，它必须是一个扫描；但如果你是串行执行的，我想只要一个相邻的转换就能很好地工作，只要你知道你总是从左到右串行推进。是的，我想我们快接近尾声了，不过布莱斯刚才说的话我觉得挺有道理。但我猜对很多听众来说，当谈到相邻转换与扫描时，并行与串行之间的区别，他所依赖的是一个很微妙的东西。我们可以试着用几句话在这里解释一下。但其中一个
your best talks i think i think it's called the c++ 20 synchronization library from cppcon 2019 i believe at the end of that talk that's where you give like a visualization of inclusive scan with like the upsweep and the downsweep yeah and that that is like i'm not sure if you recall, but the first time we went to, and this probably deserves a whole episode to its own. When you drove to San Francisco and we went to the Michael Park hosted, we were at Mesosphere, I believe. In that car ride on the way to San Francisco, I think previously at like a different time I had asked like I don't understand how a scan can be done in parallel like a reduction is pretty straightforward you can visualize the tree reduction and you know you just add the numbers that make sense but like a scan inherently when you visualize a scan it's carrying state and like anything that carries state it is not intuitive
我认为这是你最好的演讲之一，我想它叫做“来自CppCon 2019的C++20同步库”。在那个演讲的结尾，你给出了包含性扫描的可视化，带有一种向上扫描（upsweep）和向下扫描（downsweep）的过程。是的，我不确定你是否还记得，我们第一次去——这可能值得单独做一期节目——当你开车去旧金山，我们去了迈克尔·帕克（Michael Park）做东的地方，我们当时在Mesosphere，我想。在去旧金山的那个车程中，我想之前在不同的时间我曾问过，我不理解扫描怎么能并行完成，像归约（reduction）就相当直观，你可以把树状归约可视化，你知道，你把那些合理的数字相加就行了；但扫描本质上，当你把扫描可视化时，它带有状态，而任何带有状态的东西都是不直观的
like how you can make that work in parallel and And then you explained to me in that car ride and I was enlightened. And if you recall, we missed a certain turn that we had to take like three or four times while I was in the deep part of the explanation. But you had the aha moment in the car. Yeah, that was that was hilarious. Yeah, we were so we were talking about the the scan and then yeah a few minutes later wait did we take the wrong ah and then yes some uh colorful words were shared and then i was i was less concerned about us getting there on time than i was about you understanding the power of a parallel scan and i think too i i you were trying
关于如何让它在并行中运作。然后你在那次车程中向我解释了，我顿悟了。如果你还记得的话，在我深入解释的时候，我们错过了好几次必须转弯的路口。但你在车里有了顿悟的时刻。是的，太搞笑了。是的，我们当时在讨论扫描，然后过了一会儿——等等，我们走错了吗？啊——然后是的，伴随着一些色彩丰富的词汇被分享，比起我们能否准时到达目的地，我更关心的是你能否理解并行扫描的力量，我觉得也是，你当时正试图
to like get back on the right highway and I was still asking questions. And at one point you were just like, all right, we got to take a break. We got to pause the scan talk. Yeah. We've got to.
回到正确的公路上，而我还在不停地提问。有一刻你直接就说：“好了，我们得休息一下。我们得暂停一下扫描的讨论。”是的，我们得停一下。
And, and that, that version of scan that I showed isn't even the most efficient scan algorithm. Cause that, that was still a two pass algorithm where you didn't upsweep in a downsweep. Whereas the, the modern state-of-the-art, the scan algorithm that we have in Thrust is a single-pass algorithm.
而且，我展示的那版扫描甚至不是最高效的扫描算法。因为那依然是一个双通（two pass）算法，没有用到向上扫描和向下扫描。而现代最先进的、我们在Thrust中拥有的扫描算法是一个单通（single-pass）算法。
But it's much trickier to explain. There's a whole paper written on it that my colleague Dwayne Merrill wrote. We should link all that stuff. Yeah. Maybe we should leave. We'll leave the explanation of inclusive scan in parallel, maybe for the next episode, maybe that's what we can talk about. Implementing counter and less intuitive algorithms, parallel algorithms, we can try and explain
但解释起来要棘手得多。我的同事德韦恩·梅里尔（Dwayne Merrill）写了一整篇关于它的论文。我们应该把所有这些资料都链接上。是的。也许我们应该把包含性扫描在并行情况下的解释留到下一期节目，也许这就是我们可以讨论的内容。实现计数器和不太直观的算法、并行算法，我们可以试着在
that stuff next episode. Spicy. All right, anything else we want to highlight before we hop off here? I think that's it. I think it's a good one. All right, everybody. Thanks for listening, and we'll catch you in the next one. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下一期节目中解释这些东西。真辛辣。好了，在我们离开之前还有什么想强调的吗？我想就这些了。我觉得这是一期不错的节目。好了，各位。感谢收听，我们下期再见。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。